hello everyone and welcome to a
remarkable game from round five of this
year's Tata steel Masters Edition it is
world champion Magnus Carlsen against
both of them have had a great tournament
so far out of the four games that have
played and Magnus suffered his first
loss but uh got two wins and two draws
beating maxulu and Richard Rapport and
now uh he he faces Magnus Gotham with a
black piece it doesn't get better than
that and also let's check out how Magnus
bounced back after his loss uh tagiri in
the previous round so Magnus with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to C4 uh he
goes for the English opening with C5
Knight to F3 Knight to F6 and now Knight
to C3 Magnus goes 44 Knights of the
English or rather three nights but
abusato plays Knight to C6 and we have
the Four Knights of the English the
symmetrical line E3 we have Ponte E5 and
now usually you will see D4 here but I
guess Magnus uh thought that okay as
this is the main line obviously another
is all too well let's try to mix it up a
little bit he plays Bishop to E2 and now
another Becca grabs the full center with
the D5 so of course you're gonna capture
here you could also uh play D4 here
that's also possible but Magnus does
capture with Knight captures and the
Magnus castles here with Bishop to E7
and now Bishop back to B5 now putting
pressure on that E5 Pawn now Knight
captures an E5 is a threat Knight
captures in C3 B captors and C3 and now
just Queen to C7 adding a Defender to
the pawn Magnus strikes with D4 with C
capture C captures e captures and not
Knight captures on D4 and there is one
game in the database where uh castles
was played but here with Bishop to D7 by
nederbeck and it is now as of move 12
that we have a completely new game
so Magnus goes back Knight to F3 he
doesn't want to unnecessarily trade
pieces as that will diminish his chances
of actually winning and he would very
much like to win this game after losing
the previous one to a niche and here we
have Bishop to F6 just going after that
Rook on A1 it seems like a a tricky move
and a very risky one as your king is
still in the center of the board and the
Magnus definitely uh did his best to try
and exploit to this now you could move
the Rook with something like Rook to B1
but Magnus goes Bishop to A3 he stops
the black king from escaping to the king
side and he offers his Rook an A1 so
it's a sacrifice of the exchange another
captures that as it is the best move we
have Queen captures on A1 and now
another bag just castles here now you
could also try to defend some pawns here
but as Magnus Castle kingside he and
another Beck says uh that he will
voluntarily give up those Pawns in order
to be able to attack the white king but
just in case you're wondering yes you
can play F6 but it's very tricky look at
this rock to C1 and now if Castle's
Queen side now there's there are moves
like Bishop to E7 and now it's a very
very tricky position where it's hard to
say what to play do you move the Rook or
do you go for this uh Queen sacrifice or
basically you're gonna have Queen for
two Rooks now after Rook captures on C7
King captures you have two Rooks uh for
the for the White Queen so it's um well
it's it should be playable uh but no
Derek says Nope I want to keep the
Queens on the board and I want uh if you
decide to capture back some material I'm
gonna attack you uh on uh on the king's
side so first Rook the C1 by Magnus with
King the B8 getting the king out of that
nasty C file and now Queen captures on
G7 not afraid to open up the G file uh
and regain some material we have Rook H
to G8 and now comes Queen back to B2
here very interesting is uh to actually
capture the pawn because you allow black
turn uh infiltrate your king size for
example Bishop to G4 now attacks the
Knight Bishop E2 and now you eliminate
it to remove one of the Defenders of the
H2 pawn bishop captures an F3 and now
Rook to h8 and now you are breaking
through here on the H2 square but now
after let's say queen to C2 and queen
captures and H2 it doesn't really matter
after King to F1 you are you are okay
here there is no good way to take
advantage of this with black but still
for example Queen to H7 you can offer a
queen trade and now either white uh
accepts this or white should keep the
Queens on the board as he is down
material now we're going to see
something like Rook to C8 and now uh
well it's anyone's guess but probably
Bishop to G3 guarding the H1 square if
you go for the tricky Bishop captures on
C6 threatening Checkmate black can uh
just capture here and now if you go
greedy for Rook captures on C6 now you
even get checkmated Queen D3 check and
now whatever you do you just get the
checkmated so well it's possible to play
this
um uh maybe maybe you know it's easier
to not capture on H7 so Magnus goes back
Queen to B2 and now Bishop to G4 very
nicely done now threatening Bishop
captures on F3 and Magnus goes back
Knight to E1 the Knight is very well
placed here guarding the G2 pawn and
Magnus spent uh some 30 minutes on this
Knight to F1 move as it's not um not an
easy position to handle so here Rook to
D1 uh getting rid of one of magnus's
very strong attackers The Rook on C1
Magnus straight here Rook captures
Bishop captures and now Bishop back to
F1 adding more defense uh to the king
side Here and Now Knight the E5 here uh
Knight's the E5 while it is a fine move
uh there is a much nicer one Bishop to
G4 just to show you how the engine is uh
thinking now uh here white wants to play
H3 as soon as white plays H3 uh his
defensive setup will be much stronger
but here after Bishop to G4 you are
preventing that because now H3 will be
met with Bishop captures on H3 and now
if let's say Knight to D3 Now You're
Gonna Play A Move Like King the A8 to
get get your king to safety and now
after let's say Knight to F4 you will
play Rook to d8 I know it's very
dangerous the row can come to D1 if you
stop that let's say queen B3 then The
Rook can come to D2 and this is how you
will uh well just to grab hold of the
position with black but another Black
Friday night the E5 which also looks
like a very nice human idea and the
Magnus immediately plays H3 he says no
more G4 Square for you and now we have
Bishop to F3 uh very nicely done by uh
by nod Rebecca just putting pressure on
that G2 Pawn but also hoping that Knight
captures and F3 is played uh of course
if not then he will just re-maneuver his
bishop and this diagonal to go after
this A2 pawn and the situation on the
clock is uh this is only moved 22 both
players uh some 13 minutes on the clock
uh we have Queen to D4 now uh just uh
centralizing the queen and Rook to d8
attacking magnus's Queen here Queen to
H4 and now Bishop back to D5 now Magnus
goes after the H7 pawn queen captures an
H7 and now Bishop to C4 uh eliminating
the slide score Bishop which is a very
strong defender of the king side Bishop
to B tune output pressure on the Knight
and hear another back trades uh Bishop
captures King captures and now Queen to
C4 with check King to G1 and now Knight
back to C6 with Knight to F3 by Magnus
uh and now Queen captures on A2
here it seems like you could go for Rook
to D1 check Queen to F1 but that really
doesn't do all that much for example
King H2 Queen to F1 you're the king
escapes to G3 and nothing is really
happening here uh if you try something
like Bishop to E5 check you can just
trade Knight captures and E5 but now
Queen to h8 with check and it's black
who has problems King to C7 Queen
captures and E5 with checking to C8
Queen the C5 with the check and so on
King D7 Queen to F5 with checking to E7
and now Knight to the E5 for example uh
black is the one who will most likely
lose this game so instead another back
just goes for Queen captures and A2
eliminates that pawn and now he's ready
to start pushing his a pawn forward with
Bishop back to F6 as the bishop here is
also hanging so Bishop F6 with Tempo
attacks The Rook now Rook to D1 with
track King H2 and now Ponte A5 now the a
pawn marches down the board uh Knight
the D4 by Magnus and queen 5 just
getting the queen out of the way nicely
centralizing we have Queen backed the
seat you now attacking the rook and
queen to D6 with check with Ponte F4 by
Magnus and now another back just trades
down into into a beautiful beautiful end
game for him Rook captures on D4 now you
cannot capture with the pawn because the
bishop hangs so you have to trade
everything Bishop captures uh with uh
Knight captur Sandy for E captures and
now Queen captures an F4 with check Pawn
to G3 and now Queen captures on D4 and
we have this queen and pawn end game uh
where uh Notre back has two connected
pass pawns on the queen side bottom
Agnes also does have a past H Pawn so
it's very very difficult to see if you
can actually win this Magna starts
pushing and another back also continues
pushing on the queen side with Queen to
A2 now going after the F7 Pawn just Pawn
to F5 Magnus pushes H5 and now Queen to
h8 very nicely done going after the H5
pawn queen characters on a for Queen
captures on H5 with check King to G1 and
now Queen to F3 attacking the G3 pawn
and this position is uh much much
trickier than you might imagine here
Magnus has only uh well he has two
options that seem uh like they can be
played but there's really only one
option that can be played and that is
Queen to E8 with check
uh here you have to play Queen to E8
with the check and now you just harass
the black king all over the board Queen
t7 checking to C6 Queen to E6 with
checking to C5 now you can even play
Queen to E7 with checking to C4 Queen to
C7 with check and you just continue
harassing the black king if you try
something like Queen to C6 you just go
Queen to F4 with check now you're
threatening to pick up this pawn and if
black queen blocks then you just repeat
Quinta uh C7 with check let's say queen
king to D3 now I play Queen Queen to F7
and moves um uh such as these will keep
white in the game the problem is you can
never push B5 uh Queen to B3 check for
example will eliminate this Pawn so it's
very very difficult uh it's rather
impossible for black to keep an eye on
the F5 Pawn while also uh having the B5
Square covered and the B7 Square covered
so you don't lose any of the pawns
however that's exactly where Magnus
blunders the entire game instead of this
queen to E8 check he went for the other
idea King to H2 and it seems like a
perfectly valid idea you you defend the
king here your king is even safer on H2
as there are far few squares from uh
where the black queen can check the
white king but the problem is now the
game is completely winning for another
back uh so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the winning idea
that while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Queen to E2
with check that's how you do it uh the
the point is you covered the B5 square
and that's how you will advance the pawn
once the pawn is Advanced the B5 then
the king will have many many squares to
start marching forward and you will be
able to hide the king behind the pawn
behind your queen and continue advancing
the pawn and now it doesn't matter where
the where the King goes if you go King
to H3 then uh a series of let's say
queen to F1 check King H4 and the B5 is
enough to start advancing that pawn
let's say queen to A6 You're Gonna Play
Queen to C4 with check if King goes to
G5 You're Gonna Play Queen to C5 just
cover uh every Square so you don't get
checked if Queen to A5 you're gonna play
King to B7 now already your king is
marching forward let's say queen to A2
uh Queen to C4 you offer a queen trade
this if Queen to G2 checking to be 6n
and so on and so on your king will March
forward and help Advance the past Pawn
to becoming a queen so instead of King
the H3 Magnus played King to G1 but now
a different problem arises Queen to E5
now attacks the G3 pawn and also covers
the V5 Square from here so here King to
F2 again Magnus defends but now Pawn to
B5 and you can see how in the other line
where um uh we didn't play King to H2 in
that position uh black never really had
an option of advancing the pawn to B5 so
here Queen B4 now King to B7 we have
Pawn to G4 Magnus wants to trade the
remaining Pawn of the board uh F
captures Queen captures and now King to
B6 and now with the white king boxed in
like this uh the White Queen will not be
able to stop the advancement of the pawn
uh it's even uh to to too easy to do
this so the only way for magnets to
survive this would be to create some
sort of uh some sort of a trick where he
I don't even know how it would be
possible so here we have Queen to G8 and
now another big just continues advancing
the pawn pawn to B4 we have King F3 not
just King to B5 we have King back to G2
now Queen to E2 with check King G3 Queen
E3 check King to G2 and now Pawn to B3
the queen nicely defends the pawn queen
to B8 with check with King the uh C4 we
have Queen to G8 with check and now King
the C3 uh the the the position plays
itself basically Queen to C8 with check
with King to D2 and now Queen to Hate by
Magnus sort of keeping an end at B2
square but it doesn't matter King to C2
we have Queen to C8 with check now comes
King to D1 Queen to h8 once again uh
guarding the square and now Queen to D2
with check we have King to G3 and pawn
to B2 and here it was in this position
unmove 60 did Magnus got up from the
table he went to the bathroom uh
probably to refresh himself and to
prepare himself for this new reality
that he is now about to lose his second
classical game in a row which which did
not happen for quite a few years I I
think last time that happened was in
2015 in Norway chess uh but uh still uh
it's it's very rare that he will lose
one classical game losing two games in
the same tournament in a row uh that's
almost unimaginable uh but yeah it was
here in this position that Magnus
Carlsen returned to the to the table
said at the board looked looked at the
position a little bit and he was in this
position on move 60 that Magnus Carlsen
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so beautifully done
by another by cabbage who not only takes
down the world classical Champion with
the black pieces but also is now in so
lead of the Tata still Masters and here
uh you resign because if if you deliver
this check let's say queen to H1 check
Queen E1 check blocks check while
delivering check now you have to trade
and now the pawn will be prom promoted
and if you don't if you've got something
like Queen H7 still okay you can play
this guard is the B1 Square uh King to
C1 and now uh Queen to H one check King
to C2 and now after one more check is
given if you give this check then we
block while delivering check uh Queen D3
blocks check and delivers check and also
if Queen the C6 with check also Queen to
C3 check will block check force a trade
and now the pass Pawn will be winning
so yeah really nicely done B2 uh played
and the Magnus resigns a classical game
not something anyone would have
um uh thought that that would happen
especially since he had a rest day he he
played some sports yesterday uh he had
the white pieces uh like uh I said that
when Anisha faced Magnus that okay he
defeated him uh with the white pieces
but here another big had the black
pieces against the world champion in all
time formats uh and he just crushed him
so okay Magnus played a bit of a risky
line uh but uh you know it should
definitely hold If he if he plays the
best the best moves but that's just
another outplay them uh and there was
nothing Magnus could do these are the
standings after uh the the few rounds
that we've covered uh you can see that
uh sorry uh this uh nope that's the
wrong one let me just load up the the
actual one
yeah that's the that's the right one I
accidentally loaded up the the wrong one
so these are the standings after uh
sorry there we go after the the five
rounds that were played uh Abdus with
four out of five an incredible result uh
if you if you consider that he already
faced Magnus Carlsen uh followed by
Anish giri with three and a half points
also a player who has defeated Magnus
Carlsen in this tournament uh then we
have uh with three points uh karwana and
pragnananda then with two and a half
points uh Arjun negregation and Wesley
saw and Parham maxulu which two points
uh Levon Magnus Carlson and Richard
absolutely incredible to see Levon and
the Magnus uh in uh sharing ninth and
ten Place basically uh in uh 12th uh and
basically 12 to 14 with one and a half
Point bookish euron Farm forest and
Vincent kaimer so incredible uh
incredible tournament uh incredible turn
of events every round we'll see what
happens will Magnus be able to bounce
back from two losses everyone said that
he could bounce back from one loss that
he will just you know now Crush everyone
but now after two classical losses in a
row we'll see if you if you will be able
to bounce back and we'll save at least a
part of the tournament uh so yeah that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed that I
would like to thank revision reptiles
YouTube I love Adrian and Jude easy
ovens is the best Derek king and the
Richard F sash for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
steel until it finishes so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day